good morning Hank it's Tuesday so
dishonesty has a story place in American
politics but for the past several
decades maybe our most prominent form of
deception has been the so called
non-denial denial I first heard that
term while reading all the President's
Men about the Watergate cover-up that
led to President Richard Nixon's
resignation back in 1974 like Nixon's
press secretary Ronald Ziegler responded
to reports about the scandal by saying
stories are being run based on hearsay
innuendo guilt by association
he also said no one in the White House
at any time directed acts of sabotage
the first statement is just a criticism
of the press the second one is very
carefully worded to be technically true
like no one in that is physically inside
the White House directed that is
directly oversaw acts of sabotage
President Nixon had still totally
committed obstruction of justice of
course but there was no direction of
acts of sabotage from inside the White
House in the decade since the non-denial
denial has become almost beautiful in
its linguistic sophistication like after
the National Enquirer published reports
of 2008 Democratic presidential hopeful
John Edwards having a child outside of
his marriage he said that's tabloid
trash they're full of lies but of course
saying the tabloids are full of lies
it's not the same thing as saying that
the tabloid is lying about that
particular story he later said that his
wife was beautiful and sexy which again
is not the same thing as saying he
wasn't having an affair and then finally
he said the story's just false false is
a word you hear a lot in non-denial
denials it's useful because it's vague
like maybe the story is false because
you didn't actually have a child with
your mistress maybe the story is false
because the story claimed you met your
mistress at noon when in fact it was
1206 maybe the most famous example of a
non-denial denial came from Bill Clinton
who said I did not have sexual relations
with that woman miss Lewinsky now that
seemed at first a total unambiguous
denial but it turned out Bill Clinton
was using sexual relations to refer to a
specific sexual act and not to you know
like a sexual relationship this strategy
of narrowing the definition of guilt so
much that you are no longer guilty is
quite a popular one like when CIA
director John Brennan was asked if the
CIA was spying on Senate aides
investigating the CIA's interrogation
techniques he responded as far as the
allegation of CIA hacking into Senate
computers nothing could be further from
the truth
because there was no password theft it
didn't meet Brennan's
definition of hacking but you know other
than that it was completely true so it
really it could have been further from
the truth because it was just was just
that one step away from total truth
there are many other kinds of non-denial
denials both Bill Clinton and Ronald
Reagan for instance used there's no
evidence of that and I can't recall you
also often hear people not quite answer
the question like during the Bridgegate
investigation New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie said I am NOT a bully in
response to a question that was not
about whether he was a bully and then
there's the ancient tactic of
criticizing the press like allegations
by the press might be called defamatory
or libelous or slanderous or my personal
favorite outrageous but of course lots
of things that are outrageous also
happened to be true and words like
defamatory and libelous are like false
they're vague they don't refute specific
accusations I bring this up because I
think it's important to pay attention to
the language of the people who are or
wish to be our leaders especially in an
election season as voters we need to be
asking when you tweet that something is
false or a lie
what exactly is false or inaccurate
about it when you call someone a liar -
what lies are you referring and when you
issue a denial what precisely are you
denying and are you in fact denying it
language exists to facilitate
communication to make my thoughts
transparent to you and yours transparent
to me but we have to remember that
language is a tool that can also be used
to render things opaque Hank I hope
you're having fun on tour I will see you
on Friday